how did you know you were rushing
through your first film and and the
whole process like what was it feedback
was it an epiphany you've added or just
me watch my own material you know I
think that filmmakers need to be honest
with themselves
I'm not everything that makes them be
great but at the same time everything
you make should be a testing ground for
your next project we are filmmakers it's
a craft people don't remember we were
craftsmen crafts ladies you know and so
it's a matter of and with film you bring
all the different crafts people together
to be able to create one one piece of
work and it's one of those things that
people don't think about enough and and
I always talk you'll do a bunch of
students say they listen like you'll
learn more by doing than you will in
school yeah because you have to do it
you have to fail you have to figure out
what works it doesn't work but I learned
that I was rushing through things for
watching stuff myself after the fact you
know I was I was a bit naive a bit
arrogant and thinking that you know what
I would make would make money and and
thankfully it all has it's interesting
it's like I have a very different
business model I keep saying that but
like all my films have been profitable
except for one and it's only feeling
that we saw
it's very strange you know because I I
firmly believed in the actual
distribution yeah I believe in what I
call a ten thousand dollar screening or
you were actually netting $10,000 at a
screening so like you know we'll have
this like I'll rent the largest place
possible yo sell as many tickets as we
can we tear the ticket prices you know
$10 $35 125 that's $125 and so we your
friends at $10 just get you in the film
35 is the film and after-party
you're the 125 is a pre-party screening
and after-party and then also like you
know like swag bag sorts of stuff then
we hand out film bills or we sell
advertising in I literally make all that
I read all these sorts of things so I
literally will net at least 10 grand you
know per screening and I generally do
that in the early early parts of film
release and I've been successful at it
so you do your string no number of those
together you're in the black and you
know so it's like just
model that I've created for myself and I
also have some I've always have some
other sort of IP involved like friends
with aka it told about earlier the film
tanked it didn't do well but I made more
money in a cocktail book that I made
associated with the project that I did
on the film itself but I still equate
that to the folks who's all part of than
saying the same property so I always
think about like creating different
revenue streams for every project like
for instance with billboard you know we
have a creative radio station WT YT 960
we have the webseries we have now the
interactive play and we have the feature
film and then with all that stuff we can
sell you sponsorships yeah because we're
actually you know showing off brands
within the content that we've created
and so that drives a whole other level
of income how many sponsorships do you
have from Billboard there's nine nine
sponsors yeah and and and I'll be very
candid they go anywhere from nine
thousand up to forty thousand I say so
that and nine thousand is your minimum
entry point yeah and do you know that
it's a fantastic job did you have prior
business relationships with any of the
sponsors or you just cold call or cold
call but also to was like I firmly
believe that filmmakers need to build
audience early on and so what we did
first is we created the radio station WT
YT 960 where now there's well over a
thousand bands on it from I think we're
in 22 countries 49 states and so I did
that was so I knew that we could that we
had an audience and no sponsor is gonna
give you anything unless you could prove
that they're going to have impression
counts and unless they know that they're
gonna have some sort of audience for the
project so not only do we have those
thousand bands but then we have their
fans and we did we did a we did an
average of them each of the bands
averaged at least 6,000 fans so all of a
sudden you know a thousand bands to
6,000 fans you're at you know what six
million reach you know
which is pretty astronomical for a small
independent film and so we were able to
get those numbers because we could prove
that we actually had you know
impressions and so we had audience and
that's what's that's what's pretty
fascinating that all that because it's
not easy to do but we were able to do it
with the film screenings where you said
you netted 10 grand with what's your
split with the theater like how are you
rent them
you rent them so you buy it out ok
there's so much that's not every
screening that we do is 10 grand
early on we do we do it's interesting
because we found that we do better at
events when we have events around our
projects that we do just like you know
running a week or something like that so
we're gonna be you know like
reformulating that model a little bit
and taking it on the road but like what
we do is like we will launch the film by
that $10,000 screening because then that
also to us frees up capital and also
build buzz that we then have a very good
box office and that's how that's how it
all how it's all generated so I've
written about this a couple of times
like I wrote something for a TED hopes
blog about the 10,000 dollar screening
and things and it's very possible every
filmmaker could do it they really can
interesting is is because I produce and
I create outside of so far outside the
system of New York and LA that there's
anomalies that happen because of that
like I don't know if you could do it in
LA quite honestly is because there's so
many filmmakers making so many films
here that I don't know if it would work
nor in New York but it does work it
where I'm from you know so I was just
gonna ask you so it do you have such a
leg up because it's a smaller area they
want to support local artists they're
excited maybe they're even in the film
yeah absolutely to a point but at the
same time again it has its pluses and
minuses you know it's harder for me to
produce in my hometown because of that
well I have to bring in everybody you
know like there's colleges that have you
know film programs but I end up teaching
everybody and then once I teach them
they stick around for a couple years
then they come to LA you know because
cuz I don't produce enough work you know
fast enough to be able to sustain like
full-time people
over the course of a long period of time
so we end up bringing in people from new
york philadelphia yo for crew and also
some cast then we also fly casting from
LA so that's a problem it's like when
you're producing in places that are more
remote they do cost more people don't
think about that you'll catering per
diem lodging transportation but then
also to is that people be like oh well
you get you know tax incentives and yada
yada yada but you only get those if you
qualify for them and so there is a
certain thing that you have to be aware
of and again it comes down to the
business side of things
like for instance I produce off a cash
flow now many filmmakers do that so I
don't qualify for a lot of tax
incentives because I don't have you know
the eight hundred thousand dollars in
the bank you know after July 1st after
they passed there that passed their
budget
you know I basically you know make money
and spend money that's my business
bottle and so I don't qualify ok yes so
it's a matter of understanding if for
instance like crusing outside of like
New York and LA and and Atlanta
familiars just really need to know what
their state tax incentive is before they
even you know start thinking about
budgeting it also is where they're
getting their capital from you know
there's also different you know tricks
and everything else that you can do to
be able to Maine to obtain capital I am
horrible at crowdfunding I have a hard
time asking people for money I think
that's one reason why I have very few
equity partners and what I do
I generally spend my own money my wife
and my money quite frankly like we are
about 82 percent of the of the resources
that it took to make billboard and so
but what I believe it all in like I feel
like I need a skin in the game but I'm
so horrible of asking for money
horrible I need another producer to ask
for money I can make the money trust me
I can make it money just a matter of
like I have a hard time asking for money
well then there's two probably maybe you
feel freedom too if you know okay well
this is also literally my or our project
you know if it's your money if it's 80
percent your money there's less need to
get approval from other people for
things
oh you're actually
right but at the same time there's a lot
more risk there's a lot more sleepless
nights you know I'm worried about making
payroll I'm worried about like literally
people watch the film my my you know the
people that work with me said it's
become bit autobiographical and it's
interesting because we've been screening
the film much success thank God and you
know some people push back like other
don't like the ending and things and I'm
like you know I understand that and and
once they then they lieutenants are
arguing with me in the Q&A which doesn't
make any sense to me but like but like
and and so like I literally asked them a
simple question have you ever owned a
business well I'm like no have you ever
owned a business have you ever had to
make payroll
well my father did but did you well my
father lost his business I'm like
exactly exactly and so the thing is is
like it's like people really can't walk
the walk unless they've talked that you
know they can talk to talk with us they
walk the walk you know and so like my
wife and I literally put everything out
a lot it's it's it's it's scary as hell
it's risky as hell but I've made money
in the past so I keep doing it you know
thank God you know like we have been
successful and also too is like people
can't look at filmmaking as a lottery I
have so many friends so many peers that
see getting into Sundance as a lottery
ticket that like you know they're going
to like have this huge career and
everything else and and and that sort of
thing
I love Sundance I've had films at
Sundance that's not what I'm saying at
all but it's a matter of people have to
look at the long tail or their careers
that everything is a building block and
you don't want to be a flash in the pan
because there's only a few of them well
you probably knee in them on your on
your two hands right and so how many
films have been produced over the past
ten years that have gone nowhere you
know and so people have to think about
it more from a business perspective and
realizing how they can make money at it
early on and it's just a matter of not
looking at it as like oh my god I'm
gonna make this movie I'm gonna be rich
but looking at as I'm making the movie
this is part of my business you know
like if you make widgets you might
make different widgets over the course
of your of your factories career right
if you're a filmmaker you're gonna make
different films over the course of your
career it's not all dependent upon one
film you know so just think about it
that way it's not it's not like no and
I'm not saying that I've been hugely
successful you know but I've made money
you know and I do this full-time you
know and and you know but it's a grind I
worked my butt off still to this day you
know and I'd lead by example on the
first one in my studio at 7:00 a.m. a
little generally last one we leave at
6:30 7 o'clock you know I would doing
that for 10 years you know working on
the same project you know so it's a
matter of vision it's a matter of just
really working and and yeah it's six and
a half days a week
you